was our race genetically engineered
6,000 years ago where we created by
beings from distant space to work as
laborers toward some unknown end from
ancient cave paintings to the conquest
of space we have grappled with the
truths of our beginnings but what if the
question of our origin falls outside the
realm of social acceptability what would
happen to our culture if we were to
discover that we as a race are no more
than the result of a genetic experiment
conducted by a superior life-form
there's no time 13 o clock
hey everybody its episode 103 about the
Anunnaki and ancient aliens yes alien
astronauts all that kind of [ __ ] yeah we
primed the show with those two movie
reviews that we did last week you know
with Prometheus and alien covenants yeah
this is kind of a related yes topic yeah
we're doing like a whole feed yeah we're
pretty sure that Ridley Scott got his
ideas from this subject here you know it
just so yeah zecharia sitchin and what's
it Erich von däniken
Chariots of the Gods actually stuff like
oh the ancient and the ancient aliens
came here and built all the [ __ ] you
know or yeah gave the ancient people
there are magic alien technology our
religions were leftover stories of what
happened between us and beings from the
heavens Yeah right I got stuff wasn't
that kind of like the fourth Indiana
Jones movie - yeah sorta basically I
really don't know they're gonna do it
again they're making another one I heard
really oh that's not Shia LaBeouf
swinging through the trees with a with
it with it with the correct with it
seriously when I saw that scene the
first I saw that I saw the movie on a
plane and I'm like I'm watching it going
real you really somebody wrote that down
on a piece of paper in a script and then
you got a whole bunch of people to go
along with it they couldn't be any
better now a Shia LaBeouf is exactly the
kind of guy you need swinging through
the trees I can't even trust that dude
inside of Kentucky Fried Chicken to me
that was like way worse than the whole
refrigerator nuclear the last thing they
didn't bother me too much I mean at
least that's sort of plausible yeah you
know nuclear bomb is a bomb you know
yeah so you can protect yourself from a
bomb but yeah maybe now real well I
think that it blew that it blew that
refrigerator out a couple hundred yards
and it'd be hard to survive that I think
well yeah it would rattle your skull
around on the inside
especially ones from back in those days
I mean nowadays they're all made
everything's made of plastic yeah right
so but yeah before we get to that you
know we want to do our regular shoutouts
and all that usual crap that we do um as
we said our last movie reviews were a
twofer it was prometheus and alien
covenant so go check that out if you
haven't yet also check out our Zazzle
store at zazzle.com plush 13 o'clock and
we still have this really cool kick-ass
t-shirts and a tote bag yeah and yeah
more people need to buy those cuz I
spent a long time designing those I'm
gonna make everybody feel guilty now
yeah we're still trying to get to our
goal to $1,000 a month on patreon yeah I
changed it on patreon patreon yeah and
we hit the 1,000 we're gonna release the
new show yeah I think you guys are gonna
like the new show yes if y'all like a
new show you could always cut us off the
Patriots are dying like that but yeah
you can do that yeah we'll stop making
that joke certainly okay you gotta lose
yeah I mean we got one with for most
4,000 subscribers if ever if only like
one in four people you know where to
donate a dollar then you know actually
don't do a dollar because if you do a
dollar patreon gets most of that dollar
it's not even really I think we end up
bacon oil like 10 cents the last I heard
I don't know if they changed it it's
better to give like at least two dollars
yeah that way we'll probably get like a
dollar yeah what you know which you know
if you know we only had a thousand
people give us a dollar actually if we
about 700 I think
they had 700 people give us one two
dollars yeah or a dollar fifty we do
yeah we definitely make it you kids that
grew up in the eighties know what I'm
talking about
you better often better off did you
never saw that with John Cusack
no okay so let's I think I reference it
on the show before and again you were
just like looking to be like what the
[ __ ] are you doing yeah it's a movie
it's a lot of people that grew up in the
80s saw that maybe it's not cable see
that one oh it was funny it's still
funny I thought the other day and it
speaking of patreon we actually have a
new patron whose name is Natalia
yeah thanks thanks and also one of our
other patrons now did we decide what are
we at now on patrons 30 or 33 Patriot
about 300 a month yes okay we got a ways
to go
yeah we saw it a long way to go but you
know it's common it won't take that long
I don't think and did we decide that
this his names
Jamin right jamón jamón you know Jamie
Jamie yeah yes
he actually upped his support on patreon
I did so hooray thank you very much
and I'm sorry because every time it's
like I always forget cuz I was like we
established how to pronounce his name
and then every time I have to pronounce
it again I'm always just like she's
Jamie I can't ya see I think it is cuz I
think it was I was trying to get all
fancy and like French or Spanish
thinking yeah well that's kind of my
thing
that's what I do yeah so yeah so thank
you for doing that also I think I
mentioned on last week's show that I've
started like designing some kind of
giallo themed card games and board games
and [ __ ] like that yeah I actually have
three games done and two of them have
expansion packs yeah
the first one which is a murder mystery
game it's kind of like clue but you can
you know you can like replay it and
stuff it's not like just one murder
mystery where you figure it out and you
can't play it anymore it's a different
one every time and that one's done I've
actually ordered a copy of it and a copy
of the expansion pack and if I like how
it looks when I get it then I can put
that one on sale I've seen the plans for
it it looks really good but when we get
in person we'll see we'll see how it
came out because you never know I mean
you know when you design [ __ ] and if
those of your graphic designers even if
not a graphic designer I'm sure you
probably know it's like when you design
something the way it looks on the screen
sometimes is very very different than
how it looks when it's printed all goes
well we'll make a commercial for it will
yeah put a commercial show and I also
did another one that was kind of like um
it's kind of like mystery mansion or
betrayal at house on the hill where you
kind of like build the mansion Ichigo
it's like a Honda but it's kind of based
on the Suspiria three mothers kind of
thing I was initially gonna call it our
ladies of sorrow until I discovered that
there was already an RPG that was called
that
so I decided to call it the three
sorrows and stents that'll be the next
one and then I also made one that's like
it's like a kind of a card game like
apples to apples or cards against
humanity' or SH movie or something where
it's just like cards with words on them
that are like giallo movie titles and
like you make the best one and then you
know pitch a movie to the judge or
whatever and get points so that one is
called the cursive names of nightmares
and that'll be the third one out and
that also has like a horror Gore
extension pack so it'll be fun so like I
said I'm trying to order all of them to
see how they come out in the printing
and then I'll put them up for sale and
I'll let you guys know when that happens
now let's go to our news stories I was
initially only going to do one and I
wanted to do like a space-themed one
because we're talking about the Anunnaki
and stuff I said we'll do like a whole
fun space show because I mean to be
honest we've been doing like a lot of
true crime lately yeah bummer so I
thought this one would be kind of more
fun and [ __ ] but then speaking of space
though before we forget yeah I want to
mention something last night we saw a
cross a movie that's right we did watch
soldier yeah because remember we talked
about oh yeah we talked to [ __ ] on what
you call it on the Prometheus and sub
show because you were trying to cram it
into this yeah because everything has to
be part of the crustal Spears yes so you
know so he was trying to cram that into
the whole Prometheus and alien mythos
what do you think um I didn't like wait
yeah I gotta see what you're getting at
where it's like kind of it's not really
exactly the same because he was a a guy
he was a rude Android or he wasn't
reporting to the guys who who wrote the
script all right
they wanted it to be that he was
replaced
he and his team write a place by
replicants by like ROI baddies well they
were like genetically engineered and
engineered but they said there was only
something to I remember they said there
was some little tweaks and stuff more -
well something something like the story
goes as there was supposed to be
prototype replicates right okay I got
like Roy batty remember Roy yeah Roy
there were guys like that I can see it
was a pretty good movie though
yeah a sample space wrap like you said
cross all says very little in it says
very little
doesn't have to say anything though
that's true he's just looking good in
that movie too he's he he does he looks
all rugged and mean yeah he like buffed
up
yeah and he's always like staring at the
camera yeah and all like he's gonna like
rip your [ __ ] backbone a t-shirt you
know how that was cool flick heads good
guys pretty good old school effects lots
of good sets it was an expensive movie
and they didn't it didn't make any yeah
you could tell yeah it kind of reminds
me of Waterworld remember water world
looked like Waterworld and Riddick one
yeah how like dune a head you know like
some of the guys who just kind of look
like the satyr car yeah I thought the
cinematography on it was kind of nice
you know what I think a lot of the
problem was the title the title yeah
very forgettable time soldier soldier
yeah big deal it's just you know it
doesn't have all of pizzazz like it's
not very memorable like I said it sounds
like a Jean Claude Van Damme yeah
directed deeply keV it I think they had
they given it a better title they might
have done better might have done better
it might have been remembered yeah but
I'm a blu-ray it was good it got a cheap
on blu-ray
I recommend that movie to any fans of
that genre it was much better than I was
expecting
yeah it's good yeah it's good it was it
was good space Rambo space Rambo yeah
space ramble yeah so uh okay so before
we get to the space story a couple
people sent me this Florida man video
and I have to address it because it's
Florida man we live in Florida and we
were just talking about the whole
alligator thing and like the guy chuck
in the alligator and through the window
the window of the Wendy's drive-through
or whatever so this is a video that went
viral in this past week and I absolutely
find the I found the video in the
Orlando Sentinel website so here's that
starts with a Florida man who carried a
live alligator into a Jacksonville
convenience store to get some beer and
ran around inside the business with the
reptile tucked under his arm has been
arrested
surprisingly yeah the Florida Fish and
Wildlife Conservation Commission said
Wednesday that Robert Timothy bar 28 who
was also known as
be Stratton I don't know why he has like
a is that you know got an alien is he
like a superhero I'm like anybody's got
two names like you must be a cousin
sketchy stuff so he was arrested as was
his buddy Kevin keenum 23 both men were
charged with illegal possession of an
American alligator because illegal
exhibition of dangerous wildlife and
cruelty tales right so something that
you normally get away with they got
charged for because they did it on video
you see the video I mean I feel bad for
the alligator how big is the alligator
four to five feet okay
he's carrying underneath his arm yeah
okay the best thing it's a yeah it's a
viral video I'll put it in the in the
YouTube video like the part of because
it is actually kind of funny like I said
I feel I feel kind of bad yeah so Barr
was seen in a viral video running around
the convenience store with the 4 to 5
foot alligator this is the best part
though he told the television station
wjx 47 that he didn't know how he ended
up with the alligator no no let me let
me say it no he didn't know how he ended
up with alligator no I got a glass well
that ties right in to the next thing
that he said he said he doesn't remember
how I got the alligator he said quote
this store sells some good liquor and I
drank a lot of it that night I don't
even remember coming up here where do
you get an alligator like he's him and
his buddy or drunk I guess yeah run
around the streets whatever it is
they're doing he decides he's Troy he's
so drunk today and remember going to the
convenience store but yeah he's like
okay well at some stage we have to go to
the convenience store and go to get more
beer we need an alligator yeah find me
an alligator any day
he found it now he had that alligator at
his house mainline alligator now anyway
you could run around with a five-foot
alligator without in heaven just he had
death that tail is that that you that
that alligator knows yeah yeah it had
duct tape over its mouth yeah but still
this the tail alone at five feet of tail
could just hurt you well yeah it's like
I said it's it's not a huge alligator
but it's like it it's a decent size
I'll just be a handful though four or
five feet that's pretty good handful
yeah one of the men it says one of the
men stepped on the alligators snout
which was wrapped in duct tape he then
grabbed it by the neck held it aloft and
yelled Florida State baby for the
Florida State I should add that's the
Seminoles the Gators
that's the University of Florida so he
got get your [ __ ] straight poor
alligator it's all fun and games yeah so
I don't know they didn't say I mean I
guess they took yeah I hope they just
let it go but yeah so this guy was huh
they told me what I did was stupid they
had to tell you that no [ __ ] yeah they
told me what I did was stupid and that I
would be facing some charges probably go
to jail probably not one way or the
other I get along with my given [ __ ]
ten days we'll see he says they're all
first-degree misdemeanors thank you so I
don't he'll probably just get a fine or
something yeah he'll be doing the rounds
on them on the on the YouTube talk shows
oh I'm sure because it's just like
became a total me and like this dumbass
like I think they're a convenience store
it's a good idea yeah you'd only be able
to figure that out in a in a state like
Florida or maybe Ohio yeah oh hi I was
the Florida Florida of the north or the
sort of the Midwest do you prefer so
yeah so I had I had a lot of listeners
send me that story were like check those
out so yeah it really happened it is
like I said it's a very funny
even though I feel bad for the poor
little alligator I don't know why I did
that well because that more Jar I know I
told you that you should fill the whole
job drink with something that looks like
oh well I didn't say you had to fill it
up with alcohol alcohol you could fill
it up with something that looked like
alcohol you could just fill up with
water and you can say it was a good
shake that I couldn't drink that you
could say it was moonshine no Matthew
Judy died and I'm legitimate this is the
real thing I got it I got a screwdriver
but see I just look out now my jar feels
inadequate in America size rules the
bigger the better
size matters I got a shirt but Jenny
says that on the front unless you're
talking about a tumor okay so the other
news story it's not exactly a news story
and I want to know if you knew about
this because I never heard of this [ __ ]
and I was just like reading about it
because I was looking for space related
news stories and I'm like what the [ __ ]
I never heard of that have you heard of
the space Kingdom of as Gardea no okay
so it's not just me yeah so this is an
actual thing that this guy started he's
like a Russian scientist and
philanthropist and he's a billionaire
like he owns a business and everything
like that and he has decided that he's
going to start the first space nation
okay so it's gonna be like in a I'm
guessing that it's gonna be in a you
know like a space station type of thing
eventually he wants to establish a moon
colony and he has a website he has
actually launched a satellite into space
like honored so he's way ahead of like
other people okay yeah so he doesn't
have a satellite in space he did pay to
have that put up there and that is the
first foray into he wants this to be a
nation state of its own the space
Kingdom of Oz Gardea and if you want to
sign up and you want
live on his space station or on his
purported moon colony that will be
coming soon I'm sure then you can sign
up and you can become a citizen okay now
apparently a whole bunch of people did
that the first time I did this is only
Ben I think he first announced it in
late 2016
and then he's actually been trying to
get the this year he's been trying to
get the UN to recognize him as a
nation-state he's not trying to like
take over the universe or anything like
that he's just trying to get he's just
trying to get his one space Kingdom
understand it seen as like a sovereign
nation and it's like you have a home
planet or is it just an area in it's
going to be an area in space but
eventually like I said he wants to
establish a moon colony so you can
apparently you can go to the website and
you can apply for citizenship now a
bunch of people did it and then
apparently they were like there was too
many or they were getting a bunch of
bums I don't know what it was so they
said oh we're gonna make the application
process harder so I think they're to
about 250 250 thousand three hundred
thousand people because apparently you
know there a lot of people want to get
the [ __ ] off this planet which you know
you can't blame him sometimes yes he
definitely wants to remind it is and he
actually has the means to do so which is
kind of funny now when I was looking at
when I was reading the Wikipedia page
about this guy some like space Kingdom
of Asgardian he has a saddle I never
heard of that I never hear of that so I
was like reading all about it it's this
big long [ __ ] Wikipedia page and he's
totally serious it's a satellite dude
it's not just nothing it's just there
I've been broadcasting any signals or oh
I don't know I think he just put it up
there is like this is the area this is
gonna be like it contained in this
satellite it's just a little bitty
satellite right but he I think that was
just like his first going look I had the
money to do it ridiculous but the funny
thing is when I was reading the
Wikipedia page about this they're like
this surprisingly this is not the first
guy to try to pull this kind of stunt
where I'm just gonna go up in space and
take it over however there was one and
this happened way the hell back in 1949
there was this guy named James
Mangan I want to say our Mangin he
wanted to start the nation of celestial
space
or Celestia right now this guy was a lot
more ballsy he's like I own all the
space yeah so if you want to come up
here you gotta pay me yeah because all
the space is just kind of minds me of
like back in the 1400s when you had
Europeans all right in European nobles
and kings just claiming all of the new
world that's exactly what this guy's
yeah yeah I mean and like Spain would
claim all of the new world
England claimed all of the new world
everybody claimed all of the new world
they didn't have a single troop there I
didn't sent you know I mean nothing no
well yeah Eskil means to implement any
of these claims all that stuff got
worked out later by the American
colonies America Mexico worked it out by
fighting it out over who owned the
European thralls guns and [ __ ] later but
it's ours we own your [ __ ] yeah with
that [ __ ] over it's ours they'll just
draw a map on them on a globe and go
yeah this is all ours they aren't even
consulted in the Native Americans that
other guys go out there and slug it out
I just kind of had a laugh at this guy I
mean fair play to this guy it was 1949
nobody had gone into space really so he
was kind of ahead of the curb he's like
you know hey I could lay claim to entire
space and then if they want to go up
there and put satellites and do nuclear
testing they'd have to come to me first
except nobody did everybody's like no we
don't have to do nothing I think those
aliens are gonna have a lot to say over
who owns space I know they're gonna
we're gonna show up and we're showing up
late to the game I guarantee you know
I'd be like wait you guys saw him in
space no no no no when your solar system
is dead in the middle of our territory
they're gonna tell us like that yeah we
on your planet wouldn't that be funny if
like this space Kingdom of Asgardian I
and he like actually was able to like go
to some other planet or something and
like set up a thing and then there's
already aliens there being like yeah the
[ __ ] you think you're doing man
these
these you have my hounds these UFOs that
you know that the air foresees yeah
that's the cops
yeah the set off to the park rangers
yeah they're like you guys alright so
this guy like I said he's he's kind of a
nut but you know he's a scientist he's
really into space and I don't know if
he's just trying to make a point or if
he's like really serious about it or
anything but he has billions of dollars
and that's what he wants to spend it on
he's like I wanted to put a satellite up
in there I want it to be a nation state
where people can go if they don't want
to live on the earth they can come live
on our moon colony and it'll all be cool
and all this other kind of stuff so I
would like to proclaim right here on
this very show that I own all the air
yeah so if you want to continue money
into my PayPal account immediately or
I'm just gonna shut off the whole
planets oxygen and you're all gonna
suffocate it's just another pipe dream
yeah there's gonna be corporations up
there and earth you know you the US
Europe and China are gonna be on Mars
and in the moon and they're gonna
dispute over yeah they're gonna they're
gonna fight over stuff when they get
there I don't want to live on the moon
maybe not I don't I don't know II would
not want to go well if it was a nice
moon colony I wouldn't mind Mars I don't
know if I'd want to go that far
let's see Masood it seems too far away I
mean the moon's far away too
but you could actually live on Mars with
the property yeah that's true you could
live there what have you forgot Samir
[ __ ] back on earth think of how long it
would take to get back and get it know
you'd make everything you need right
whatever Mars knowing you you would get
all the way to Mars and then you'd be
like [ __ ] I forgot my glasses yeah and
then we'll have to go all to make
anything you need right there on Mars I
would hope so it's like I said I'm just
I'm not going all the way back to earth
every time I bet you there's a whole
bunch of water underneath this
underneath the service I kind of suspect
there probably is too because they even
like when they when they're little
little little guy likes great I will
have a little guy the little room
I would take over like a cave see it off
pump it full of oxygen build down in
there don't be nice I could do that
probably I can do that probably all
right so that will do it for our news
segment you didn't do oh you didn't do
the news song yeah [ __ ] it no it's too
late now this is the news that was the
news he's committed to this is how much
I love pickles we buy tickles in these
big huge jars it's everything they're
really good all right so that'll do it
for our news segment and our shout outs
so now stay tuned for our discussion
about ancient aliens and the Anunnaki
enjoy okay so our main topic today is
ancient aliens yeah ancient aliens you
know we're at where this concept came
from gonna involve zecharia sitchin and
erich von daniken and those guys and you
know what it is they actually believe
what they're saying and and and if
there's anything to this yeah I mean
really what I want to do because really
the whole ancient aliens subculture I
guess you would call it
yeah um is so vast and it has like so
many different people
that I sort of wanted to just focus on
zecharia sitchin the anodizing
Nibiru that kind of stuff it's not just
one thing it's a whole scene right it
has evolved since its first yeah and
then maybe like make mention of a few
other little things that turned up on
the hna lien show or that you know or
that proponents of that theory like
often talk about yeah and there's weird
stuff that's kind of related to the
ancient aliens scene that appeared even
as far back as the early 1900s like in
the 1920s to the 1950s you know with
fake fake Indian Veda Vedic texts about
you know flying machines and stuff
that's that's been debunked as no that's
that's the 50s that's not an ancient
text right yeah you know so that's kind
of related to this I don't think we're
gonna get into that too much we might
just mention Italy yeah well I just did
mention
yeah I mean like I said I kind of wanted
to mention a few other things too even
though mainly I'm gonna be focusing on
the Anunnaki the Sumerian the Sumerian
text dr. Riya Sitchin Erich von däniken
version of this now the thing about the
whole ancient aliens thing is that
there's kind of two or three different
forks of it I guess you could call it
now there's the one fork that just
basically says aliens came here sometime
in the distant past and helped out yeah
ancient people like building the
pyramids or what teaching them how to
things are had like alien technology and
blah blah Prometheus alien coven and
they fight back all right yeah there's
also another strain of thought which
says that they came here and mingled
with humans yeah dating you become the
Starchild skull you know what they're
talking about and also you know the mess
of American Indian themes of where yeah
they're coming down they're breeding
with our women right it says so in that
kind of stuff and actually the the
Anunnaki
zecharia sitchin you know thread of this
now he has actually proposed now he has
passed away he he actually got I I
thought this is very funny but I looked
on his Wikipedia page he actually got a
Lifetime Achievement Award from
coast-to-coast am yeah well he was on
there all the time sure but he wrote a
[ __ ] ton of books about this yeah he
sold a lot of books about it too and
yeah he sold millions and millions of
books and they've actually been
translated into like 25 languages or
something like that this so this guy's
works are very very popular now let me
go back a little bit to where maybe the
ancient aliens idea might have come from
like you said you know there have been
sort of hints of oh maybe you know
ancient aliens from you know from the
early 20th century idea has been around
for a long time but I think it kind of
took off in the late 60s and 70s maybe
because of Carl Sagan and is Shelikof
skis 1966 book called intelligent life
in the universe now in that book they
had a chapter where they kind of said
well it's possible and maybe we should
look in
to the possibility that aliens have
visited humans at some point in the past
um you know it's not impossible it's not
crazy you know maybe there's something
to it now they didn't say that there was
any evidence for it they didn't even say
it was probable he says pause they just
said it was possible and maybe we should
keep an open mind if that's all they
said yeah and they weren't actually even
talking about aliens coming here during
the time of man either they're talking
about a Prius pre-human era you know
maybe the dinosaur age yeah you know
they're you know people forget the whole
concept of deep time there's a lot of
time yeah pass stretches out behind us a
long long way lot to happen back there
and yeah and really humans have only
been a blip on yeah Carl Sagan in later
years tended to think that because of
him mentioning it in this book that he
kind of gave the crazier [ __ ] that came
along later some legitimacy like he's
like who's did their business right just
like people seem to take that idea in
the late 60s and early 70s and kinda ran
with it right one of these people was
Erich von Daniken who very famously
wrote Chariots of the Gods about all
these aliens came to earth and gave you
know gave ancient people their alien
technology or helped them out in
building things and you know yeah and we
want to point out that Sitchin and Erich
von Daniken or not trained scientists or
historians really they're not archeology
ours anything they they they were
writers yeah and that's what they did
they wrote books they wrote entertaining
books and because of their methods that
you have to really take what they're
saying as in a grain of salt
when Sitchin appeared on the scene it
was pre-internet there was no real way
that people in the general public could
actually check these Sumerian texts for
themselves at that time well that time
has passed
anybody can get on the internet now
there are sites and what was name of
that site but if you switch in was wrong
or err bought anything is wrong
something like that there's one called
Sitchin was wrong com yeah that's run by
a PhD in ancient languages in ancient
Near East cultures yeah
there's also one called ancient aliens
debunked yeah it has a bunch of links
but if you go to there are several
databases online I think the University
of Chicago has one and there might be
another one where all of the ancient
Sumerian texts that zecharia sitchin was
using to kind of construct his
particular ancient alien theories about
the Anunnaki yeah you made it yourself
now where you can read them yourself
because they have all been translated
the ones that they found and like I said
there's even Sumerian dictionaries
that's right and you can even search it
based upon keywords like you can go in
there and ask for any references of the
Anunnaki and it will show you in the
text right where they all are right and
I kind of want to get into that a little
bit too because there's kind of I really
got fascinated by this there's a really
good documentary and it's on YouTube for
free it was made by a guy named Chris
white yeah awesome awesome documentaries
three hours three hours and 10 minutes
long and it's fascinating and it's very
well written and very very well done
very entertaining you can sit back and
yeah we watched the whole thing last
night we just that back and drank and
watched it that's right yeah three hours
and yeah we're gonna put a link to that
in the description yeah I'll put a link
in the description to that program can
do a whole lot more work than we can
given the time that we have right now
yeah because think II can even show you
the evidence show you everything yeah I
mean cuz like I said that one kind of
touched on a lot of ancient aliens where
it's like I said I guess I wanted to
just concentrate more on anyway it
basically covers a generalization of the
entire ancient alien scene yeah cuz
there's a lot of them and like I said a
lot of them were coming at it from
different direction now zecharia sitchin
came onto the scene in the 70s his first
book was called the 12th planet and I'll
explained that reference in a minute but
he had a lot of he had something called
the earth chronicles and he wrote like a
bunch of them subsequently basically his
whole idea was that many many years ago
the Anunnaki who were mentioned in
Sumerian tests and they and they really
are yeah they're not what he says there
but I'll get to the room innit that
these were alien beings from a planet
called Nibiru yeah which was a traveling
planet which was out beyond Neptune or
out beyond Pluto and only circled
through the solar system every 3,600
years or whatever
and that these Annunaki came to earth to
mine gold yeah because they needed gold
for their madness atmosphere their
absolutely whatever raises yeah to
deflect rays or something right so these
Anunnaki came to the earth to mine gold
discovered that it was too much work and
basically genetically made humans yes
like a slave like a slave race yeah so
mine gold for them to mine gold for them
yeah and then there was also a whole
thing because he ties the whole thing in
two with when the Anunnaki came in
they're kind of giants and then they
would breed with humans and stuff so he
kind of ties it in with the biblical
Nephilim story also of titans and ripe
on Mount Olympus and everything right so
it's all been tied in with that now
where did he get these ideas from
zecharia sitchin claimed that he taught
himself to read Sumerian cuneiform right
I'm not sure how true that is
I don't think he could actually read it
himself I think he read translations he
might have yeah and then reinterpreted
the translation right and so a lot of
the things that he says in his books one
he doesn't source that her back it up or
say exactly where it says that yeah
he'll make a claim that oh and it said
and you know and the Anunnaki did this
and that and this and that we doesn't
say where in the text where the text
that he gets that news and he was saying
that in a time where the lay person
could not check the text yeah I could
check that now you could go on that site
and look for that on there there was
there was only a very small number of
people academics who could read Sumerian
cuneiform right you know and and it's
still you know obviously it's not
something that everyone learns but you
can go and read translations of it now
they're freely available
Jenny and I and I'm and I'm sure many in
the audience grew up in the pre-internet
age in that era information was hard to
find it was very hard to find somebody
could give you a line of [ __ ] and you
might believe it for awhile even and a
lot you could go to a library and not
find this you can go to a library and
not find translations of the Sumerian
texts yeah but nowadays you can go
online and find that you know
to really speed it up research and it
speeded up debunking a lot oh yeah
tremendously you can do now and in a few
days what would have taken months and
months back in the pre-internet age
right you gotta worry about mailing
documents to you and then xeroxing
things and yeah man we used to do a
whole unit in school about how to use
the library for research yeah maybe
would take a long time yeah so you know
and then your library wouldn't have the
information she'd had to contact a
faraway library it was just and they
send you the [ __ ] right and it was like
it was [ __ ] like that but the thing is
is that when Zecharia Sitchin's books
first came out there was basically no
way for the lay person who was reading
his book and enjoying it to check what
he was saying was true so here's the
thing he says in his book without
sourcing it that the word Anunnaki
translates to those who from heaven came
you right now even at the time ancient
language scholars sumerian scholars were
calling [ __ ] on that but because
there was no internet there was no it
was no clean up when your information
disseminated to the public so it's not
what Anunnaki means that's not what
Anunnaki means through the word Anunnaki
basically means of royal seed or royal
bloodline right Anunnaki the ones that
Anu made right are the offspring of a
new or on who is a great god of heaven
yeah and key who is his consort the
personification of the earth like the
earth mother figure right and in this
same pantheon of course as a flood tale
and the flood tales it's basically it's
a it's one of the other tellings of
Noah's Ark and the flood so Anu and his
wife are basically El Shaddai and what
was what was the wife's name originally
before they demoted to a serpent
Asura Asura in the old Hebrew stories
God also had a wife in the garden named
Asura the the story got rebooted and
re-edited to wear ashore was demoted to
a serpent for helping out Adam and Eve
okay well El Shaddai also had sons one
of those sons was Yahweh another one of
those sons was Bale alright Yahweh chose
Israel
so basically when you have in the
Sumerian text that the Anunnaki were the
ones that a new maid and his wife what
they're talking about is the sons of God
in other words the Anunnaki were angels
because actually in the Hebrew Pantheon
Yahweh would have been one of God's sons
originally who Yahweh originally was an
angel okay the same with the other ones
that shows the other Hebrew tribes later
as cult of Yahweh gets bigger Yahweh and
hell should I get merged and it says
Yahweh is God and that you know and then
all then his brothers all get demoted to
angels it's a system that ancient
religions just the way ancient religions
did things is where they wrote things
you know that's what I mean it's like
the more you learn about the Sumerian
you know creation myths and things like
that I don't know why Sitchin latched on
to the Sumerian but and making it sound
like aliens because it's really not that
different
not that dim from Old Testament from the
Old Testament it's not that different
from you know any of the other Greek
reality Egyptian Pantheon sits that same
pantheon system and basically all it is
is they are personifying forces of
nature or celestial bodies as gods which
is something that most ancient cultures
did yeah one of the one of the things
that's different between the Sumerian
Pantheon and the Hebrew Pantheon is that
according to most of the people that
really have studied it extensively the
Sumerian Pantheon it's not quite as
exciting that's kind of boring yeah the
stuff that they have now I'll tell you
one thing is that the Sumerian version
of the flood called you know the Epic of
Gilgamesh is far better written than
Genesis the nemesis flood story it's
longer and it's more descriptive it's
pretty cool in a way the Genesis flood
version of that story is kind of the
hillbilly version it's very
stripped-down kind of simple yeah I
would do we actually read that in my
humanities class when I was in college
so yeah so that's kind of something
something that's uh that it's always
been really interested in interesting to
me like the older versions of the Old
Testament flood story but yeah so what
you're seeing here is zecharia sitchin
basically he wanted to come to the
conclusion or he came to the conclusion
first that these Anunnaki the Sumerians
were actually talking about aliens so
then he sort of went through a lot of
the Sumerian writings like the Anu
malysh and all that those types of
things and kind of made it so that it
seemed like these Anunnaki were coming
down from space yeah
his translations know Sumerian scholar
agrees with the translations that he has
made he's got an objective in his mind
telling you this story and he's tweaking
what he knows of the Sumerian text to
make it really read that way or read
more like that way but cement says he's
just making up out of whole cloth yeah
because I mean why on earth would he
have why would he say in all his
writings that Anunnaki means those from
the heavens came like it mate so it
would make it sound like they were
coming from outer space like they're
aliens but that's not what that word
means and it's nowhere in the text and
it's nowhere in that and nowhere in the
stories is like right it's no different
than any other and any other stories of
angels in the Old Testament stories
about angels and he also says - they
actually said this on an episode of
ancient aliens like word for word they
said this they said that in the Sumerian
text it says that the Anunnaki came down
from the sky in flying vehicles and that
is complete [ __ ] it never says that
and you can search the entire everything
they've translated Sumerian and nothing
ever says that and the thing that
ancient aliens the show used to
illustrate these so-called winget
vehicles was like it was basically it
was this frieze that had some carvings
on it like a relief and in the top of it
there was like a little disc with little
wings on it it looks just like the
Egyptian solar disk well that's what it
is what it is Sumerian solar disk and
the Egyptians ripped that off from the
Sumerians which is a round disc with big
elegant wings with mines on come out the
side because the Sun is in the sky it's
moving so therefore it's flying so
therefore not to have wings that gives
you the idea that it moves you know yeah
and the thing that they don't show you -
and I kind of want to get into this in a
little bit as well is that I think that
a lot of this ancient alien stuff
that they put on the TV show and that
they put in the books and stuff what
they'll do is they'll take [ __ ] out of
context yeah so like I find it
instructive zat the ancient alien TV
show when they wanted to make you
believe that the Anunnaki that the
Sumerian text said that the Anunnaki
came down in flying vehicles
they showed a freeze that had this
little disc with wings on it and that
was all it had they didn't show you the
many many many other freezes that has
that exact same artwork on it that it
has like it's a little disc over here
with wings and then on the other side is
a moon it's obviously the Sun and the
moon right and when you see the other
freezes that becomes very obvious to you
that it's like oh that's the Sun and
that's the moon but see they didn't want
you to know that so they didn't show you
that right and we were watching that
same program that explains why even in
the middle there in the medieval era the
son of the moon had phases in them yeah
because in ER during Roman times they
had faces in them that's the way their
cults driana son on the moon because in
pre cultic Roman cultic times the son of
the moon were gods and goddesses so
they're kind of persona fighting them as
beings in the heavens Sun the moon yeah
faces right and I think that and I was
gonna say that too is that another thing
and this isn't so much a zecharia
sitchin thing but this is just a general
ancient aliens thing is that they will
often point to a couple of medieval
Byzantine era paintings and go look it's
you know back in the sky behind the
Virgin Mary there's there's a spacecraft
back in the UFO now let's showing you
one of them but they're only showing you
one of them yeah if they showed you
other examples of paintings from that
era that were of the same biblical
passage yeah you would very quickly see
that that is not a UFO that there it's
either the son of the lone yeah it's
clouds yeah or the faces of angels or
yeah with an angel popping out or with
sunrays coming out of it or were the
ring of angels which was a way that a
lot of medieval painters portrayed the
Spirit of God and they had the thing
down from hey had me going with one
painting they have a thing that looks
like an arrowhead with a man sitting in
it yeah if you look real closely there's
a crescent back on it it's the moon it's
the moon it's the moon and when you then
they show you other paintings of how
there are lots of them lots and lots of
paintings of how the medieval painted
the moon and the Sun and yet as always a
man's face a crescent it's moving and
then they put like a little arrow arrows
to make it that's how they demonstrated
that in the Middle Ages that was the
symbolism it seems like you know it
shows like ancient aliens will always
show you the one or two paintings where
this little cloud of angels isn't very
clear or it's like you know kind of a
shitty looking quality or something so
it's like oh look it could be an alien
or look it's it's shooting a laser beam
and maybe ever into marriage and marry
that's because it's impregnating
versioning marry that's what that that's
all that little dove flying down towards
Mary's belly yeah a laser beam yeah and
there's a bunch of paintings bunch of
them you know it seems very deceptive
the way they go about things and they're
really leaving a lot of context out you
know that would explain a lot of these
quote-unquote anomalies that turn up in
this kind of thing yeah and this stuff
goes across cultures because they're
doing the same thing with Mesoamerican
stuff the Mesoamerican like Incan and
Aztec their language was like a system
of little faces and pitchers they
weren't even really like Chinese
pictograms or hieroglyphs they were a
lot cooler in the way it was they were
like emojis
language based on emojis it could either
represent a consonant or a syllable the
first sound that that emoji means like
fish might like a picture of fish might
be or whatever you know their language
was for that or it might mean fish
itself and then they would turn it
around backwards and do all these weird
things with it it kind of like you would
online playing games with emojis like
reversing them well because of that
weird language the way it looked you
know back before they knew what it said
it gave them a lot of leeway to go oh
this has something to do with aliens and
then some of the statues from some of
the tribes that they had we're basically
really kawaii statues like you know like
cute Japanese stuff yeah and one of the
famous ones is this thing that looks
like a damn airplane but they're only
showing you that thing that looks like
an airplane they're not showing you the
other stuff that it came with
salamanders and lizards and you can see
that there's a style like this kawaii
style to these yes because they meant
ionised animals
you and they were all animals that were
important to these Mesoamericans if you
take that one looks like an airplane you
can put it right next to a Suckerfish
and that's what it is they had this
little Suckerfish with the eyes on the
top and its fins look like wings and it
looks like a little jet the fish looks
like a little jet right and that's what
that little plane is it's not a plane
it's like I said and I think that
happens with a lot of these kind of out
of place artifacts like you said and
like I said they will take one thing
that was weird and show you that show
you that but not show you the hundreds
of other things that don't look weird
things that don't look where little
cutesy statues of lizard frogs and birds
yeah brush it like that but that tell
you what the reason why that little
statue looks like a jet is because the
fish looks like a jet it's like a jet
when you put a picture of the fish right
next to it you go yeah that's what it is
yeah it's in that style it's very
obvious that that's what is when you see
a photo the fish that they were
depicting yes a little flattened out
sucker fish kind of shark shaped with
fins that look like wings or the lure
big round it was a delta wing shaped
fish yeah just like a double wing jet
and it's like I said it's very obvious
when you see the real thing that it was
based upon so I don't so I don't think
there's anything to explain there Russ
so let's take a break right now because
we're about at the halfway point and
then we get back I want to talk a little
bit a bit more about Annunaki uncheck
button nibiru yeah and maybe what's that
stuff really and maybe talk some more
about some other stuff that people said
about building projects that they have
helped with and stuff oh yeah yeah yeah
so we'll get to that in a minute we will
be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put spotlight on ourselves and
you can put a spotlight on yourselves if
you go ahead and pick up on these shirts
today you guys are gonna love them links
in the description
WWL com at 13 o'clock yes ago check out
our store at wwl comm slash 13 o'clock
we got these four cool new t-shirt
designs plus all our old ones if you'd
rather get one of the old ones but these
ones are awesome and you should check
them out they're also available in
women's cut they look really cute JT's
got some so thank you go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
that's why there is so significant
because we are willing to paper now one
of the other very funny things they
mentioned on this documentary and like I
said they love this [ __ ] on ancient
aliens and even when I was doing a
Google search for Anunnaki these
carvings and reliefs kept coming up and
I'll put them in the YouTube video so
you can see what they look like they're
usually like these big guys and they
have like helmets or turbans it looks
like it looks like they have
wristwatches on oh yeah yeah and they
have wings and [ __ ] like that so ancient
aliens and I think zecharia sitchin was
kind of pointing out it's like oh look
these are obviously spacemen or or
whatever ya know before before we get
into this too much though I want to say
something just because we're we don't
really believe in that in the evidence
that they're showing us for the sanction
alien I think we have good reasons why
we don't believe in that it it doesn't
necessarily mean that doesn't mean that
I don't believe in extraterrestrials
well I different question actually I do
believe in extraterrestrials and I do
think that some of these sightings that
military police and airline pilots have
had in the past not all of them are
easily dismissed you know there's
there's like secondary evidence of like
radar signatures and more than one
witness at a time so is it possible that
ancient people may have seen mysterious
things in the sky oh hell yeah sure it's
possible sure and you know you have
meteors you have you know falling stars
you know everything that they saw that
they couldn't explain was something
mysterious could they have seen an
extraterrestrial craft in the sky like
something out of you know Phoenix lights
yeah they could have we weren't there we
don't know but I tell you one thing the
evidence that these guys are presenting
in this ancient alien scene the evidence
is not good they're missed there they're
forcing this evidence to fit this theory
and we're going to talk more about this
at yeah and like I said nothing that
they're showing is really all that
compelling no and they all have
completely normal rational explanation
so I don't think that you need to posit
an extraterrestrial intelligence and
another thing is is that if
extraterrestrials came here they
wouldn't leave behind any physical
evidence it would be just like today
when if there's a cop sitting in a car
and he sees a triangle fly over his
vehicle that kills you know I mean he's
just gonna report back to smash saw a
UFO but that's it
yeah there's not gonna be the hard
evidence afterwards right the ancients
may have seen things like that but they
wouldn't have any hard evidence they
wouldn't there wouldn't be any way of
knowing it wouldn't be any way of
knowing whether or not I saw it or not
there wouldn't be they would have no way
of knowing whether whether it was
extraterrestrial or not and they'd have
no way to really give us a reliable
message throughout time that you know I
mean they wouldn't be able to leave
anything behind to let us know because
no matter what they draw we could
interpret it as something else
well yeah and I think that's kind of the
problem with a lot of this stuff and you
know I don't know if zecharia sitchin
necessarily thought that he was
bullshitting or if he actually did
believe this stuff but it does seem like
a lot of them use selective editing yes
selectively showing of evidence and like
leaving important things out if you ask
me Sitchin and Daniken they said they
saw this idea and they go yeah extra
fresh so it could have come here in the
past there'd be no way of knowing all
right so let's go ahead and find some of
these weird anomalies in the past and
say well there's the evidence because
it'll make a good book these are writers
okay or a writer wants to write a book
and sell a book nowadays it's easy to
disprove the evidence that they're
showing yeah you know I mean you could
say no that's not what that is that's
not a helicopter you know that's a
hieroglyph that's broken apart it's just
stuff like that you know I think they
knew they were writing fiction it was
you know cool fiction or they had
convinced themselves or they had so
convinced themselves that ancient aliens
thing was true that they just went
looking for [ __ ] that would prove it and
anything that wouldn't prove it or would
disprove it they just ignored it Eric
which is an again a lot of people to
Erich von Daniken may have convinced
himself he sounds like he believes it
that's what I mean if you can convince
yourself then it's easier to convince
others because you actually believe it
and I think if you swallow your own
[ __ ] long enough I think eventually
you will yeah I think I think Sitchin
knew he was kind of AI
one call a hoax I think he he was Renu
he was writing a book
he knew he was writing a book that would
sell I mean he must have known that he
was not a Sumerian scholar exactly and
he must have known that he wasn't really
faithfully translating yeah because some
of his shits way off he was trolling and
here's another thing too like I said if
you go right now and Google Anunnaki
probably one of the most or two of the
most famous images that come up are
these two like quote unquote Sumerian
reliefs that look like winged it dudes
and one of them kind of has a bird head
or something
and they have these little things in
their hands where they're like pointing
at [ __ ] like a pinecone and they well
yeah I'm gonna get to that yeah and they
look like they have wristwatches on and
[ __ ] like that
now the problem about these is one
they're not Sumerian they're Akkadian
yeah - they don't have anything to do
with the Anunnaki they're not Anunnaki
that's not what they are another Genie
what they are is they are essentially
fertility genies yeah and you can see
this when it's explained when the
iconography is explained - is a very
common iconography the little
quote-unquote wristwatches they're
wearing they usually have them on both
wrists and sometimes they have them on
like headbands - it basically looks like
a little Daisy
yeah and what that is is that is the
symbol of the goddess Ishtar who is the
fertility goddess right there like even
on the Ishtar Gate in Babylon you know
you can see these little Daisy looking
yeah rosette patterns also the Queen of
Heaven yeah and that's her thing so what
these genies are is they're basically
they're fertilizing the the things
they're holding in their hands are
either a male date flower or a pinecone
and they're always pointing them at a
date tree which is a sign of fertility
and sometimes there's the king in there
and [ __ ] so it's basically a fertility
picture is basically what it is so it
doesn't have anything to do with
Anunnaki it doesn't have anything to do
with that and they said the reason that
they have wings is because the ancient
people saw that flowers and plants were
fertilized by birds and bees so
obviously these genies that represented
fertility would also have wings
so that's all it is these are not
spacemen they're not they're not helmets
there's nothing like that they're not
wristwatches that they're wearing
it's just that was their little outfit
they're just little genies they're
fertilizing Gator a lot of notice a lot
of people like to modernize what ancient
cultures are giving us you know the men
like this well it's got wings I mean you
know but you know it's got to be an
alien no it's just a man with wings it's
Jeannie yeah their thinking was was very
different from ours you know
nobody says mercury like the God like
the Roman god mercury was the aliens
like why everybody pick on the Sumerians
in Ezekiel you know there's a there's a
there's a passive little tail there that
every som of the ancient alien guys want
to say as a description of a UFO
Ezekiel's wheel yeah yeah Ezekiel's
wheel and if you really look at look at
what it is that they're talking about
and the icon the icons that they used
back in those days that's that's not
what they're talking about they're
talking about God's throne yeah it's a
big chair right it's got wheels on it's
got wings and it's got faces of animals
I mean and it's got four corners it the
reason why it has wings is because
they're saying it flies yeah if it's got
wings it flies yeah like a bird a wheel
if it's wheels roll that means it can
roll across the ground like a carriage
all right a wheel within a wheel means
it can roll fast because you got a wheel
and it rolls make that wheel roll inside
another really the rolling even advanced
talk about if you were at least yeah and
if you were actually see the thrones
that King sat on in the days of that
writing you'll see exactly what they're
talking about this yeah wings carved on
them and faces carved on them in animals
and because you know your throne was
pimpin yeah your throne could fly your
throat could roll as a car and an
airplane that's what they're talking
about and it shoots lightning yeah like
I said the ancient people what they did
it people still do it nowadays yeah and
you know people back then we're really
their brains were no different than ours
what they do is they tend to personify
or exaggerate things that they know
right you know whether this was
celestial bodies whether it was the
passing of the seasons
whether it was chariots when they were
talking about gods then they would just
take something that they knew like a
chariot or thrown
and just pimp it out yeah obviously it
would be I'm rich I got an airplane
right but Meyer plants got jets and
rockets and it shoots laser beams
they're talking about and now I want to
talk a little bit about Nibiru because
this is another thing where Sitchin's
translation of this is just totally
totally off now for whatever reason and
I think it was just because he got the
idea from this one little clay cylinder
that's Sumerian that actually kind of
shows it's like a big dot was like a
bunch of other little dots around it now
from this
zecharia sitchin extrapolated that the
Sumerians thought that there were or
knew about another planet a 12th planet
that was out beyond Pluto that would
kind of circle around into the solar
system and this planet is awesome called
Planet X so this planet Nibiru was
supposedly where the Anunnaki came from
now he really reached to get Nibiru
being a planet NOW the word Nibiru does
turn up in some of the Sumerian texts
but it's not referring exactly to what
he thinks it's referring to when it
refers to a planet it's actually
referring to Jupiter because Jupiter is
the celestial body that was associated
with the god Marduk Marduk yeah so
Marduk and Jupiter are the same thing
okay this okay yeah it's exactly the
same thing in the in the Roman religions
Jupiter was God right yeah king of the
gods oh yeah that's what I mean same as
Zeus right so when Nibiru is used to you
see there it's [ __ ] awesome how all
these Pantheon czar all rip offs and
reboots of one another yeah God is
always Jupiter
so Nibiru when it appears in the text it
either means Jupiter Marduk yeah it
means a star associated with Jupiter
yeah or sometimes it means something
that's like a crossing point or an
intersection or a gateway it can mean
that too but it never ever means a
planet
outside of the because the sumerians
it's innocent in the solar system it's
never outside right and the Sumerians
only knew of five planets and the moon
and the Sun this is attested to in all
of their other texts they never
mentioned any other planets than that
they knew about the five main ones that
you can see with the naked eye on the
Sun in the moon that was it there is no
thing about no tells no telescopes they
didn't think there were 11 planets plus
Nibiru was the 12th or came circling
around and all this other [ __ ] I think
that Sitchin got that idea because of
the quote-unquote battle between Marduk
and Tiamat yeah and how it you know how
he was saying oh this was an actual
alien battle this was how the earth was
formed and then you know Tiamat was a
was another planet that got broken up
and became the asteroid belt right and
stuff like that but which you know it's
not a crazy thing because planets do hit
each other but he's kind of saying that
this happened in within human memory
yeah and that is not the case now so the
T amok was it was a cosmic space dragon
the Marduk fights and tears her body
apart and her body is used to create the
earth or the universe I think it's just
the earth
yeah but Tiamat is a dragon Tiamat also
makes an appearance in the New Testament
what they're talking about in
Revelations at the end of time when
Jesus comes back throwing the Antichrist
and the dragon into the abyss is
basically a way of describing uncreation
in other words on creating the earth
because all that has passed away and
everyone's gonna live forever and Eden
that's how I understood that story yeah
I think the problem is that a lot of
people particularly if you're already of
the bent where you want to believe the
ancient alien type of thing I think
people have a tendency to think that
ancient peoples well all of these
stories had to be based on something
that actually happened as though people
back then didn't have imaginations or
couldn't speak metaphorically or which
is kind of insulting to them I think you
know what I mean so it's not like
everything had to be based on a real
thing you know they were some of these
were just concepts they were like they
were like memes like like TMI TMI was a
meme as a dragon yeah a cosmic space
dragon yeah that was a bad thing and
Marduk
disassembles her to make the earth but
through that action he becomes God he
achieves the title of God because he
wasn't God at first he got promoted to
God that was a job title King it's
always that way you know
Jupiter became God because he overthrew
Saturn you know what same thing is you
know Zeus became God when he overthrew
his father Cronos so he took the job
title of God but general general of
heaven yeah like I said they're
basically just extrapolating human
things human things that they do and
just making them bigger and like more
cosmic and like applying against large
same things happens basically in the in
the Hebrew pantheon el shaddai is God
but in time yahweh becomes god yeah they
become fused like he ascends to that
title rest cult of yahweh takes over
Judaism at least in certain circles
Yahweh is promoted to God and that's
explained in Exodus where you know where
the burning bush tells Moses you know
I'm al should I you know your energy I'm
Yahweh you know your Lord Bale because
the bales in the original translation to
the one that your ancestor Abraham
called el shaddai yeah so so God was
just a job title that had changed it's
like a kingly progression kingly what a
shocker
yeah and since we kind of talked about
you know we're kind of getting event the
show but since we were kind of talking
about how insulting it was that ancient
people didn't have any imaginations or
that they couldn't come up with like
these cool imaginative stories let's
talk a tiny bit about this whole thing
where aliens supposedly helped build
pyramids or puma punku or some other
like yes supposedly or geological sites
that somehow ancient people couldn't
have figured out how to build one would
be the pyramids when we start with the
pyramids yeah I mean this is kind of a
common one so I don't I don't know if
everyone is really familiar with the
work that that French architect did well
that's um yeah that's been around for a
while I think it first came out in 2010
2011 that's about that I found it about
212 there's a bunch of documentaries
about it but um names who Dan I think
Sudan yeah you got you got to see his
work because he lays out how that
pyramid was made and the construction
process and they have a little animation
of it happening in fast forward and fast
motion and when you see it you go oh of
course that's it I can't believe nobody
came up with it before now because once
you see it seriously when I saw this
documentary years ago they did it the
easiest way they could yeah I was like
oh and uh I can't nobody thought of that
before you know it just seemed like the
easiest thing in the world yeah well not
easy because it's still like a lot of
work it was just a it was just a
monument to human organization yeah like
it was a highly organized highly trained
group of men working together and that
knew exactly how to deal with stone how
to move stone and it really was once you
have the plan and the whole thing was
rehearsed with little blocks a little
model and once you kind of had a plan
and you put that plan into action
they said that you they were putting us
what was at one stone would be in place
every 15 minutes construction time
really would have only been about seven
to nine years because they cut
everything beforehand like they had
everything kinda placed orders in the
quarries each one of those rocks and
they're all arrived on the sites at the
right time and they're leaving a space
inside the pyramid basically there was
there was a subway tunnel yeah inside
the pyramid itself with they filled up
that they made like inside it wasn't a
train obviously but it was like a wooden
trash it was wooden tracks with like a
sleds that slid along so you could slide
the stones and they would pull them up
they would hoist them up and they were
got also guys inside the inside the the
subway that's the subway tunnel with big
rock big wooden rods and they're using
them as levers to lever the damn things
up tracks too which is exactly the way
the Greeks said it was done was done
with levers also guys pushing and also
guys put pulling and then guys on either
side of the tracks using wooden beams to
kind of lever the sled right out the
rock the sled up the track in a way like
I said I think the whole ancient aliens
thing that aliens had to come here and
help out these poor dumb ancient people
who didn't know how to do anything that
to me is really it's kind of offensive
because these kind of [ __ ] on ya
these ancient peoples ingenuity
yeah I mean the [ __ ] they came up with
it's still stand-in there yeah it's like
you know how much [ __ ] you build now is
still gonna be stand-in there three
thousand years from now those ancient
civilizations were not democracies they
weren't liberal democracies that you
find today they were some kind of a
theocracy and they were also kind of a
dictatorship run by era monarchy
run by King and systems like that have a
certain advantages and one of the
advantages is is that if the king wants
something done it's done and they can
allocate all their resources and all
their people right to where they want
them so you don't need to have a real
high average IQ amongst your population
but if you have one genius with a
hundred and fifty IQ and you're the king
you're gonna put that guy right where
you want him and tell everyone to listen
to him and to do it and that's kind of
the way these construction of the
pyramids was all about yeah and like
highly top-down almost a military style
organization you know that's how they
did that and I kind of wanted to talk a
little bit about Pumapunku too because
this is notable for being it's in
Bolivia it's it's notable for being the
only place according to the ancient
aliens TV show that was entirely built
by extraterrestrials and this was
another thing where on ancient aliens
first of all they straight-up lied they
said that the rocks that puma punku--
were made of were granted yeah no don't
you which they're not they're sandstone
which is much easier to work with it's
much softer than granite and it's not
like you can't make things with granite
because the Egyptians did and you can
cut granite with [ __ ] copper saws and
sand yeah and yeah yeah they make the
big thing out of well this is stone
stone is very easy to work with people
have been working and working it
thousands and thousands years what do
you think the Stone Age was about right
it's like you know we know how to do
that just right just two guys with a
copper saw as dull as a butter knife and
a handful of sand can cut a huge stone
can cut granite right you can do it
dudes go easily to brightness you guys
doing it and you can see guys the saw
doesn't even have to have teeth on it no
you just need sand with his teeth on it
and probably would work it probably
wouldn't work it just has to be flat
yes like about that like the backside of
a butter knife yeah it wasn't even very
thin it was probably about what four
millimeters wide yeah but the thing
about puma punku-- that they were
talking about one it's not made of
granite it's made of sandstone to their
say oh these blocks that were too heavy
the indians that built them didn't have
writing which they didn't but they had
pictographs and it's like you know if
they could draw a picture of [ __ ] then
yeah I could do it you know it's like
how would they have made all these
really square you know shapes and stuff
if they didn't have metal chisels they
did have metal chisels yeah they could
make alloys they be alloys with copper
and they knew to put arsenic in it even
on the [ __ ] site yeah of the ruin and
they didn't show this on ancient aliens
but if you pan the camera over a little
bit yeah there are actually you can see
stone molds yeah for chisels and hammers
and stuff like that baby head of metal
you had to be a bad man to to do this
because you know I work with tools you
know I'm on garage here building
motorcycles if you have to make your own
tools you're a man there to do that
all right thanks getting them on site
these guys could around a campfire have
a bunch of rocks all right and just
starting off with rocks from that make
stone met stone working tools metal
alloys all mixed by hand so that was
like the equivalent of nuclear
physicists you know and these guys doing
that because all they did they did the
same thing that's how valuable you would
be to your people if you could sit there
and make out metal alloy tools out of
rocks and a fire and do it just on a
regular basis but yeah that's thing that
they did and then they show you that
tool photographs of what those tools
look like it looked like something I
pull out of my toolbox yeah this looks
like a chisel chisel yeah that's what I
mean it just kills me that they would
have you believe that these ancient
people who lived for thousands of
thousands of years and like you said it
been working I mean you know the human
race has been working with stones and
things like that's for yeah even longer
than that and to think that people back
then didn't know how to use things in
their environment didn't know how to
work with things we live in an era where
you get it you go into the McDonald's
drive-through and you get a coke
alright you drink it and then you throw
that into the wastebasket I've home and
never know how anything works or
yes guys here had pride in workmanship
and craftsmanship they had a lot of time
on their hands right and they were very
proud of what they were doing that was
how they got their status in society was
to make something perfectly flat to put
a really good edge on something look
it's totally square a lot of times when
you look at the stuff it does it looks
perfect it looks very square now if you
take a carpenter square and put it on
its off a little it's off a little bit
off a little bit if it was done by an
aliens and lasers it would be perfectly
square it's not perfect it's just close
enough you can't tell the human eye and
a lot of the stuff that the Greeks made
even to they realized that you didn't
want things perfectly square the
building would kind of look small if you
did that if you kind of bent the angles
in a little bit you could get what's
called forced perspective yeah to make
it look even bigger than it was yeah so
they need they knew exactly what they
were doing and the thing too is that I
mean there were a couple of other
examples that they gave on ancient
aliens where they were trying to argue
that you know the ancient Romans for
example didn't know how to lift really
heavy pieces of stone and stuff I'm like
they had crane crimes pulleys and things
like that they weren't dumb yeah they
knew how to do that and they said that
that crane had a 6-ton lifting capacity
but they could use like oh yeah yeah you
could use a whole bunch of them in
synchrony so yeah really big stuff they
knew exactly they were moving gigantic
stuff with no technology and Russia in
the seventeen hundreds 1700 they moved
this gigantic colossal stone just
basically using Russian peasants and
some rope yeah I mean all you need is
weight and counterweight if you are
average and yeah if you understand those
principles which have been the same
forever then you can move heavy [ __ ]
with not that many people you would be
surprised how few people you need and
they said the same thing you know that
and this kind of pissed me off too they
said the same thing about puma punku
they were saying oh well these stones
they're kind of there they kind of look
like h's actually and he's like oh well
they couldn't have moved them so aliens
must have levitated them okay that
escalated quickly but what they didn't
tell you was that the tops of all those
stones had like holes in them and these
holes were for ropes you put rope down
in the one that it was making a handle
on it essentially so you were making
rope handles but they didn't tell you
that on the show yeah but every
single rock had that they're not smart
enough to move those big stones and move
those big Easter Island heads well yeah
dumb guy like me is awful smart because
I can tell you what I can't move the
damn filing cabinet by myself and it's
totally full but I do know that if I tip
it on its side and then I walk it from
one corner way back and rock it back and
forth or walk it down the into the other
side of the house without breaking a
sweat
and as dumb as I am they couldn't do
that and you can do I get a smart person
realize yeah that's right and actually
the dumb people are smarter than they
look well and they showed a little clip
of this too and if this might be on
YouTube but there's a guy who decided
that he was going to build a replica of
Stonehenge in his backyard
all by himself not using any modern
tools or anything yeah yeah he's
basically using levers and wood yeah to
make Stonehenge and he's doing it by
himself by using weight counter whoo
yeah
and he had this gigantic stone weighs
tons and he's running from one side to
the next rocking it back and forth yeah
miss somebody underneath there just
slipping whoops yeah and it rocks it
brains and it raises and raises every
time rocks it goes up it takes a long
time it's a long time but you won man
that's who's trying to show that it
doesn't take and the thing is in ancient
Egypt at puma punku and bolivia it's
like you didn't hey it wasn't one man it
was hundreds of people right so you
could get a lot of work so you could get
a lot of work done I mean it wasn't that
big a deal and they were organized they
had teams just like now and when you
have a highly experienced highly trained
team of men and knew exactly what they
were doing they could really get they
could really get Rocking yeah and get
construction working fast you don't get
it done that's what they did so like I
said it's not terrible they were proud
of what they did you know and they'd sit
back and relax and drink or whatever you
know bring me the women I'm not saying
that it's impossible that aliens you
know aliens could have visited you at
some point in the past but I don't think
it's necessary to posit that to explain
these quote-unquote anomalies or these
architectural marvels or whatever
because I think humans were perfectly
capable of doing that we have you know X
Y Z this is how they did it I don't
think you need to say that there were
aliens involved it's just not a
necessary component of that people
people see things reliable people see
things the data can't be explained I
think they're extraterrestrial I don't
know if their spacecraft or some kind of
weird energy probe or something maybe
it's a dimension door looking at us from
another dimension there's no way of
knowing that yet all right but I think
there are some things that you just
can't easily explain the way even Michio
Kaku said that says I can't explain all
this away but we know that this happens
but there's no physical evidence left
behind just stories there's a chance
that that could have been happening
thousands of years ago sure but there
have been no physical evidence left
behind
yes stories if it did happen then that's
insane and over time the stories would
have been forgotten or misinterpreted so
yeah there could have been ancient
aliens but nothing of those occurrences
could have survived time it's too long
ago yeah that's what I mean so like I
said it's it's two different things I'm
not saying that aliens didn't visit I'm
just saying the evidence they're showing
is they're showing us [ __ ] and
that's not what that says it's a good
story though it's a good story bro Oh
people should actually read those books
and listen to those stories just for the
entertainment yeah there are good
stories and they're good examples of
yeah yeah that's a good idea yeah that's
not it yeah so anyway hopefully you guys
have enjoyed this rather brief and
rambling discussion of the Anunnaki and
various other ancient astronauts and
ancient aliens theories remember if you
like the show to like share subscribe on
all your social media and share with all
your friends if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page which is patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock podcasts or you can go
to our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account where you
can give a one-time donation also be
sure to check out our Zazzle store at
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock we have
t-shirts and a tote bag that you may
purchase if you wish and also check out
our latest movie review which was of
Prometheus and alien covenant kinda ties
into the whole subject matter of today's
show and that will do it for episode 103
we will see you next time bye
[Music]
it is the truth until you're not lie it
says so in the Bible
trance came here from the sky what do
they want what do they want what what
what do they want what what
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]